All right. Uh
welcome everybody um to the
third lecture um
in robot learning from fundamentals to
foundation models.
And uh today we're going to talk about
um imitation learning.
Uh
first um before we start um a couple of
notes on the course um structure.
Uh we received um a bit more feedback uh
from last week and uh we decided um
to move um from three paper
presentations uh per lecture on Mondays
to two uh and we will um offload some of
the paper presentations uh to some of
the Thursday uh sessions
uh in in that following room. Uh I think
Alexey uh will follow up uh with an
email on this uh soon cuz we were
waiting to see who uh will stay
registered and who is uh
uh not continuing the course before we
um uh shuffle things around.
Um
uh regarding the homework assignments,
um two quick notes. Uh first of all, uh
remember the first homework assignment
is due in uh about 3 days and there is
still quite a lot of um students who
have not
submitted anything or have started
working on this. So, please again don't
wait until the very last day to start
working on your uh homework assignment.
Uh
and for those who already have have
finished and um successfully uh passed
this first assignment, uh we already
released um the second homework uh last
week. Um and this will be due on March
12th.
Uh also quick note, um
you know, when you do these assignments
like and you uh work on the autograder,
you know, sometimes it's easy to see uh
if, you know, you you use a lot of AI to
solve this cuz maybe like it takes you,
you know, uh many hours for the first
like exercises and then for the next
ones, you know, you you breeze through
it in like 10 minutes or something. So,
you know, like try your best to solve
them yourself if possible.
Cool.
So, let's Oops. Let's start.
So, last lecture we defined some
notation to help us understand how we
can map from images to
observations
from image observations, sorry, to
actions. And
we also showed how
observations are different for example
from states
when we formalize policies, right? And
so we
defined all this notation and what are
like partially observable policies
versus ones that have like our fully
observable.
So, today we're going to
look at imitation learning as a kind of
first way to train
such policies in imitation
by mimicking expert trajectories. So, we
start typically by assuming that we have
access to a data set of expert
trajectories, you know, that are not
like random movements, but
they are sequences of states and actions
like let's say human driving or a human
teleoperating a robotic arm that
successfully achieves some some goal.
And we assume that these demonstrations
are optimal or show
optimal behavior to
achieve a certain goal.
And so our goal here will be to to learn
this this policy
pi theta
that imitates this behavior.
In other words, we want to find the
parameters theta from this neural
network
that when the robot sees a state S it
produces an action that is as close as
possible to what the expert would have
done.
And so in this example, for example, for
the driving in the snowing condition it
would be like
uh, imitating the action that a human
driver would have done.
Um, the the most, uh, straightforward
way how to implement, uh, imitation
learning is an algorithm called behavior
cloning or BC. Um, some of you might
already be familiar with it. Um, so
again, we we, uh, it's very simple. We
start with this data set of optimal, uh,
state and action, uh, trajectories
provided by the expert. Uh, and now for
a deterministic policy, we treat these,
uh, we we treat this as a regression
problem uh, where our goal is to, um,
find, uh, to minimize the difference
between the,
uh, action the expert took, uh, and the
action, uh, um, that our, uh, policy
predicts, uh, for the same state. Um,
and then formally, we optimize this, um,
uh, with, for example, doing a mean
squared error loss across our data set.
So, during training, we will like sample
a batch,
um, do a forward pass with the network
to get a the predicted actions, compute
the loss, um, and then back propagate it
into the network parameters. And then
you do this iteratively with your
favorite optimizer,
um, with stochastic gradient descent to
optimize your policy.
Oh, oh, what's going on here? Sorry.
Um,
to understand, um,
Okay, so, this is kind of the the
vanilla version of this algorithm. Now,
um, we have to look like when does it
fail, right? Or how does it work? Um,
and, uh, I think we touched upon this,
um, already in previous lectures, but,
um, essentially, many things can go can
go wrong.
Sorry.
Okay. Uh, essentially, um, there are a
few different, uh, differences to, uh,
let's say supervised learning, um,
um,
that we touched upon, I think in some
previous lectures like the
IID assumption.
So, in in supervised learning as we
said, we have this
IID assumption over the inputs, um,
or that they are independent and
identically distributed.
This means that your inputs X are
independent of the labels we predict.
So, if you're classifying images of
cats, your prediction for
the image A does not change the content
of the image B, right? And now in
behavioral cloning things are a little
bit different because this IID
assumption doesn't really hold.
So, let's say that we have like this
this this trajectory over here with this
four states and this this action set
connect them.
And now
we we start, this is what we're trying
to mimic and we start with our policy as
at the first state.
And then let's say that our policy makes
like a tiny error
um,
because, you know, maybe like it didn't
fully converge or for for many different
reasons, maybe like there's just a very
very small error in our prediction.
And so it leads us to a state that's
kind of like close to S2, but it's not
exactly identical, right? It could be
just like close to it.
And this brings us like slightly off
track.
And
because now this is a new state
that we didn't necessarily train on,
our next prediction most likely will
also be different, right? Because it's
like, oh wow, like we haven't seen this
state before. So, it it's very likely
that our prediction will be kind of
wrong again.
And so this will then like kind of like
start compounding drifting away from the
original
optimal trajectory.
Because we don't have this IID
assumption.
Um
So, the important thing to note here is
that um in behavior cloning the the
states visited by um the policy uh are
not necessarily always the same ones um
as the one uh visited by the expert. So,
there is oftentimes a distribution shift
between like the training data set uh
that you uh train your policy on and
then the test set where when once you
deploy your robot. Um and you can
imagine this um I mean this is I think
very easily understandable. So, it could
be tiny things like illumination changes
or you know, if we collected, let's say
like uh the self-driving car scenario,
uh you know, we collected all our
training data during daytime and then we
drive during nighttime. Or it's like
different weather conditions that
somehow make the observations look
different and then this will affect um
the the performance of our policy and it
will kind of
uh drift away.
Um
Exactly.
So,
given everything we just discussed about
distributional shift and compounding
errors, the natural question is does
behavior cloning actually work in the
real world?
And the answer is actually it it can
work. It does work. Um here this is a um
a video from uh 2016 from um Nvidia um
uh for uh self-driving uh a self-driving
policy um that, you know, they train a
deep neural network to uh map raw pixels
from a single front-facing camera
directly to steering uh commands. And
so,
um
So, in the beginning, I don't know if
they showed us it it didn't work that
well. Oh, look, no hands.
Um in the beginning, it didn't like work
amazing, but then they kind of collected
more data
uh and kind of got this behavior cloning
algorithm to work.
Um, and so this is I think one of this
like first kind of
um, like prototypes we saw from like
end-to-end driving
being deployed in in like a real world.
Um,
and um,
so the question is like why did it
actually work, right? Like we just said
like okay, we have these issues with,
you know, drift uh,
for states not visited and for for cars
this is like is very very difficult to
generalize, right? Um,
there is one one case one simple case
here for for cars that I want to like
uh, work
work you through on
uh, some tricks that, you know, um, have
been developed to make to address this
issue.
So imagine that we have this car, right?
Um, and you know, when we drive um,
usually we we try to kind of
stay in the center of the lane, right?
Like we don't go like doing like crazy
curves and drifts and so on, right? So
most of our training data will be to
just drive straight.
Um,
something like this, right?
Now,
with this um, drifting error, um, you
know, it can be that for whatever reason
we do like, you know, some prediction
that doesn't go as well and you know,
instead of going straight we kind of
start drifting slowly towards the side.
This is actually not um, this is quite
dangerous for cars, right? Uh,
um, but the the the problem is
compounded by this this this effect that
um, you know, this is a state we have
never visited before because we all our
training data consists of just driving
straight. So when the policy like sees
this it's like, oh wow, I like this is
completely new to me. I have no clue
what idea what to do here. Um and also
collecting data for a human driver for a
such a uh dangerous situation is
difficult, right? Like you don't want to
like you know crash your car into the
side to you know learn how to uh what to
do in in such a situation.
Uh
so that's exactly the problem, right?
This is like very difficult state to
have in your training data. Um and
difficult um
to
uh to recover from this.
So to solve this um the the this uh
Nvidia paper um they
uh came up with a strategy that involved
using three cameras instead of one. So a
center camera or two side uh and two
side cameras.
Um and so they applied a very simple
trick that essentially um
they created this you know this they
augmented this data set um with examples
from the side cameras. And for the uh
camera that's looking left um they uh
labeled this always as you know steering
right. And for the camera that's looking
uh right they labeled it all the time as
um steer uh left. Right? Um so kind of
like creating these virtual actions.
And um this essentially then tricks the
model into learning a recovery policy
without ever needing a human driver to
actually crash the car during data
collection. Uh so this is like quite
quite um
quite nice trick.
Um
uh
to add this fake data to kind of like
simulate uh self-recovery um behaviors.
Now um this trick was actually also
applied here in Zurich. Um
I think I've I forgot to put the the
paper name and the year, but it's around
like the the same time I think I
believe.
Um and they applied it not for um,
autonomous um,
self-driving, but for quadcopter flying
uh, through dense forests.
Um,
and uh, this is actually very cool, um,
because it's kind of like a similar
situation um, for that is difficult to
collect data for flying cuz like we
humans like don't naturally fly. Um, and
so what they did here is
um,
do they
show?
So, uh, I think they'll show this in a
bit. Um, what they what they did is they
collected cameras, uh, sorry, they
collected data by having humans uh, walk
uh, through the forest
with a camera rig around um, around the
forehead, like essentially with three
GoPros. And then they would like this
way get this the same labels of like fly
straight, uh, if the camera looks like
to the right, um, then fly uh, to the
left, um, and so forth.
Um,
I want to show the the camera setup.
Are they showing this now?
Yeah, here we go.
So, they have this this kind of like
three cameras.
And here you can see what the the three
cameras are are seeing. And then they
uh,
they add this this virtual labels to to
learn then how to how to navigate uh,
this terrain.
So, with like go straight, uh,
go right, and go left.
Okay, uh, so we know that um,
behavior cloning can be bad, right? Um,
but how bad can we quantify it, how bad
it can be? Um, and so uh, we can for
this, um, kind of derive an formal upper
bound uh, on its performance. So,
suppose we have, um, uh, a time horizon
T,
um, the number of steps the robot needs
to finish this task, uh, and there's
some small probability epsilon that our
learned, uh, policy pi theta, um, will
make a mistake at any given time. Um,
and so, in standard supervised learning,
as we said before, um, you might expect
this, uh, error to be linear, um,
something like, uh, epsilon T, um, but
if you are, um,
uh, but this is not the case in
behavioral cloning. And, uh,
the, uh, the reason for this is that we
can define this, uh, cost function,
um, where the cost is zero if the action
matches the expert, and it's one if it
doesn't. And we assume now that, um, the
the training states, on our training
states, the probability of a mistake is
bounded by epsilon.
Um, however, um,
once we, uh, make a mistake, we move
into a state that we haven't seen
before. Um, and the analogy here is kind
of like this tightrope, uh, walker
example, right? So, where, um, there is
only a very specific, um,
sequence of actions if you want to walk
through this tightrope, and like if you
drift and fall off, like, um, it's very
difficult to recover. I mean, it's not
like bad that, you know, uh, you die or
like, like you you can have like safety
or whatever, but like, like you don't
have any demonstration data that shows
you how to get back on the on the
tightrope, right? Um, and so, um, the
probability of making, uh, mistakes for,
you know, unseen states is unbounded.
Um,
yeah, so here's the the animation, uh,
again.
And,
um, so as you can see here the um
summary, uh if you make a mistake at
step one, um you incur uh a cost of um
for all T remaining steps.
Um and so if you make your first mistake
at step two, then you will um incur cost
for T minus one steps. And if you
aggregate all these probabilities, um
the expected total error um doesn't grow
linearly, but it actually grows
quadratically. Uh which is very bad. So
it's like uh ep- epsilon uh uh T
squared. Um and so
this doesn't necessarily mean that
behavior cloning is is is bad uh per se,
but we can kind of bound its its
performance, right?
Um
So
we've mathematically kind of like seen
that behavior cloning is
um you know, like uh not linear, but
quadratic quadratic um when it starts
drifting uh from the distribution of the
states um the expert showed. Um so the
question is like how can we fix this? Um
And so if the root of the problem is
that the states visited by the expert
differ from the states visited by the
policy, um like uh our first kind of
like solution can be to well, can't we
make them kind of the same or similar?
Can we somehow close this
uh distribution uh uh shift?
And so this brings us to dagger or data
set aggregation,
um which is exactly trying to do this.
So the core idea is to make the expert
and policy distribution converge by
doing online rollouts uh during
training. So the idea is pretty simple.
Uh we first roll out the policy in the
real world, um see what states it
visits, and then ask um a human to label
those states, or or we ask uh
uh experts or um
what action, like what optimal action
they would have taken in this, uh,
state.
And so, and we don't throw away the old
data, we just simply add this new
corrective, uh, state-action pairs to
our existing data set, um, D,
and, um, then we update our policy on
this new augmented data set, and repeat
the process iteratively.
And it can be shown mathematically that,
um, this will converge to the
distribution of of state that the policy
actually sees,
um, breaking this this quadratic error
growth,
uh, earlier and bringing us to to a
linear bound, um.
So, this is great, um, but, um, one
thing to note is that, um, query like
querying human experts can be difficult
and costly um, in this process, um, like
it can take a lot of time, and there
also might be other issues like, you
know, maybe the action space might be
different, uh, from the robot and the
human, and if you're like labeling this
like in hindsight on the computer.
Um, but in in principle, like
paradoxically, this means that behavior
cloning actually works better if the
data, um, contains more mistakes and
recoveries.
Um,
as I said, like while standard dagger
is, um, quite expensive, uh, to label,
uh, like if you have thousands of
trajectories on hindsight, um, and you
know, there might be discretization
errors and so on, uh, this, uh, we can
move to a different version, which we
call a human-gated dagger, or it can
also be called online intervention,
where instead of, um, the robot
collecting data and then human labeling
later, we can let the robot run under
human supervision, like online. So,
essentially, this means that when the
robot starts making a mistake, uh, a
human in the loop can take over and
provide a partial demonstration for the
remainder of the task. And this is kind
of like much more natural and effective
as it lets humans take control um only
when it's necessary, right? Instead of
labeling like the whole thing.
Um and it's kind of like equivalent to,
you know, if you're trying to learn how
to drive a car,
uh you know, with your instructor by
your side, um
then the instructor will like, you know,
like take over or grab like the the
steering wheel only like when you're
about to crash into the curve, right?
It's not going to like drive all the
time.
Um
however, this introduces like a new
challenge, right? How do you know when
an intervention is needed? Like this is
like a subtle but, you know, still kind
of like difficult question,
um especially if you don't want like a
human constantly uh supervising the
robot and monitoring to decide when to
jump in, right? Cuz this is also um kind
of uh costly.
So, can we move beyond human supervision
supervisors uh super supervisors?
Um
so, in order for the robot to learn
uh to recognize its own uncertainty. Um
so, can we have the robot kind of ask
the human before it crashes?
Um
here I want to show one possible example
for how to automate such intervention uh
detectors and this is kind of a
uh older work from my PhD.
Uh here concretely uh we looked at
ambiguities in natural language
instruction. So, let's say um like a
human asks the robot to fetch a yellow
thing for the table, um but there are
multiple yellow objects
um on the table.
In such a scenario, ideally the robot
should uh have the ability to detect
that um this uh instruction is ambiguous
uh and that we need to query the human
back for disambiguation.
Um so in order to detect if an
instruction is ambiguous, we
um I won't go too much into details, but
we leverage like essentially a
max-margin ranking loss um that we
trained our comprehension model with. Um
so like with pairs of objects and
language uh descriptions.
Uh and so concretely during the training
this loss um
aims to guarantee that every correct
pairs of sentences and objects has
scores um
uh by a um
uh kind of um
um that has scores by a margin um M1
that uh is uh smaller than any other uh
pair with a wrong combination of object
objects and sentences.
And um so this means that at test time,
if you have more um objects within the
threshold, you can consider them
potential targets. And so then like be-
beyond our comprehension model, you can
also have a generative uh model or a
head that is able to um caption and
generate referential expressions for
these different candidates. Um so that
um
once we detect um that they are like
this number of uh potential like yellow
objects um that could be applied to, we
uh generate uh referential expressions
for each of them and ask the the human
about it.
>> Robot, fetch the red thing.
>> And this it looks something like this.
>> Fetching.
What else do you want?
>> So we asked fetch the red thing.
>> Robot, place it behind the colored dish.
>> Understood. Placing.
What else do you want?
>> Robot.
>> No, this is the the example with fetch
the yellow stuff.
>> sure. Do you mean the middle banana?
>> And there are like three different
uh yellow objects and then we generate
these kind of captions and then we can
ask uh the the user and then it says
yes, like it's the banana that we meant.
Uh and then, you know, you can keep uh
tidying up your kitchen.
>> top of the bottom object.
>> All right. So, we've covered um
distribution shifts, but there are a few
more reasons um that it would be good uh
to know why behavior cloning might fail.
Uh and one of the reasons um is uh
non-Markovian behaviors.
Uh so, for the policy uh training on the
left, we kind of um said in the last
lecture that like the actions have to um
be conditioned only on the current
state.
Um
uh or in in in essence on the current
observation in in in practice, right?
But uh the thing is that humans don't
necessarily uh choose the actions uh
based on the current state always. Like
we don't typically behave like like
this. Um so, if we see things twice, we
might not um repeat like the same
action. Um and this might be due to due
different reasons. So, uh one of them is
that we, for example, rely on context or
history um before we, you know, uh make
a decision or take an action. Um
it can also be
um
you know, our emotional state um can
also affect on us showing uh different
behaviors, uh intent, or things we have
learned from the past, right? So, um if
you're like a human driver um and you
see a cyclist, um you know, like you
don't you make some inference, you know,
not just by, you know, looking at one
image or a snapshot, but it usually like
it's based on the fact that you track,
you know, like oh, how is like the the
cyclist moving in the last 5 seconds,
and so you kind of predict how it's
going to move, and then this affects
like how like you're going to like act
as a driver,
right? And so if if as a robot you only
see like one single image of the
cyclist, like
the actions that you might choose to
predict will be different than if you
see how the cyclist is
uh
um
uh moving through the last 5 seconds.
Um
uh and I will talk about this in a
second. Maybe also another issue is that
sometimes humans have privileged
information.
This is very clearly demonstrated when
you teleoperate robots, right? So, here
you can see me teleoperating a robot
during my PhD, and as you can see like
I'm directly like seeing what the robot
is doing, right?
But now, you know, what the policy is
actually seeing are these camera
observations, right? And so, it's very
different because, you know,
with this camera observations, there are
like much more occlusions, for example,
that might affect like how you behave
than, you know, like the like the human
here who can also like move around and
see more,
and, you know, this will then lead to
different decisions than if you
teleoperate just looking at the same
observations that the uh policy is
seeing, right? So, we we also use like
the last n frames, maybe, when we are
teleoperating this way.
Um so, as a forementioned, um
uh
the if the demonstrations are
non-Markovian due to history like this
is bad, right? Because, um, when the
robot sees the exact same visual state,
uh, twice, um, but sees the expert take
two different actions,
uh, it lacks the historic history
context or, um, to understand why.
Um, our first kind of idea how to fix
this would be, well, let's just add
history to our policy, right? It's like
very simple. Instead of just taking one
frame of the current time step, we can
just, uh,
take the last, whatever, five or 10
frames and then, you know, train our
policy exactly the same way,
uh, using our favorite
sequence-to-sequence model, right? Like
you can take a LSTM, RNN, transformer,
whatever, process the last n frames, and
then train the same thing with behavior
cloning.
And so, although this seems like a great
idea, um, besides making your model, you
know, a bit more computationally
expensive, um, adding history, um, to
your policy doesn't always make things
better. Uh, in fact, it can sometimes,
um,
make things much worse.
Um, because this brings us to causal
confusion.
Um, this is a kind of a very, um, known
problem for, uh,
um, doing imitation learning with
history.
Um, the issue is here that when we give,
um, a high-capacity,
uh, model access to entire history, uh,
of observations, um,
sensors, and actions, um, they typically
have a tendency to infer spurious
correlations. So, because it's
essentially looking for, um, the easiest
way to minimize the loss, um, uh,
it always does it doesn't always
identify the the the right causal path
for it.
Um, so, imagine that, uh, for our
demonstrations, like every time, uh, the
robot opens a drawer, um, the gripper
sensor records a spike of exactly, um,
10 Newtons as it grasps the handle. Um,
the model will look at this and will
think like, "Aha, I don't need to look
at the visual state, uh, of the drawer
or the arm's position, uh, because if
the I see that if the gripper force
history shows, uh, this 10 Newton spike,
then I will trigger the pull action."
Um, and now if you deploy this on the
real robot, um, you know, maybe your
gripper slips slightly, um, or, you
know, it's a bit dusty and, uh, let's
say the sensor only reads like 2
Newtons. Um, then the model will be
confused because it thinks that, um, the
the sensor value causes the opening
action rather than the visual state of
the handle being, uh, grasped. Um, so
that the pull command will like never be
triggered.
Um, and so,
um, this is like a very, kind of, uh,
uh,
this is like one of the challenges when
you train, uh, policies with history,
like you have to regular do a lot of
regularization and look that they
actually, uh, still pay attention, um,
to the right, uh,
uh, visual states and so on,
um,
uh, to learn the the causality.
Okay, uh, let's move on to another, uh,
reason why simple imitation learning can
fail and this is, um,
what we will be talking about for the
remainder of of the lecture mostly, um,
because, uh,
um, even if we have like perfect data,
uh, kind of a big problem is, uh,
multi-modal behavior in the data.
Um,
so, uh, this means that imagine that,
you know, we are we want to like, uh,
close this drawer, um, as we discussed
in the first lecture, first of all, you
know, the if you have like a redundancy
a redundancy in your robot, uh, joints
there are like multiple ways how you
could be doing, um, kind of the same
pose with the end effector, um, and on
the other on the on the other side for
the task itself, there are also
um, very uh, infinite number of ways um,
how you can reach the handle and and
push it in, right? Um, and because there
are like infinite numbers of ways how
you can think about this, right? you can
do like a side grasp, you can like
actually grasp the handle or don't grasp
it. Uh, you can do like a top down or
you can do like, you know, 90° and
everything in between that you can think
of, right? Or you can just like push it
with the elbow.
Um, so humans when you ask them to
record this data will naturally like do
all this to show all these different
behaviors.
Um, is is that clear? Does Do you
understand? Yeah? Um, and so um, so we
have this kind of stochasticity and also
expert inconsistency, right? So there
are like multiple ways to achieve the
same goal.
Um, and all are valid in principle cuz
they all um,
achieve the same like uh, success.
Now, why is this a problem for
behavioral cloning? Um, so if you're
using our standard loss function that we
introduced in the first algorithm uh,
with um, mean squared error,
the the math essentially forces the
model to find the average of all the
demonstrations, right? Um, so if you
have like these two tracks, you know,
like you're snowboarding or something,
um, and um, you know, your expert shows
you one mode where, you know, they go
left around this tree
uh, and then um, another one shows you
how to go right or across this around
this tree um, and then the average of
those will, you know, be like driving
uh, straight into the tree.
Um, and so
uh, this will be a kind of a problem.
So, what can we do about this?
Um,
so if the if standard regression um, to
single point fails because um, the
average uh, is inconsistent uh, with the
expert data, we need a policy that can
represent multiple uh, valid peaks of
action or modes. Um so, kind of one way
or our first idea how we can uh solve
this is um you know, for example, using
uh something like a mixture of Gaussian
distributions. Um so, you represent this
with a set of uh means, covariances, and
weights.
Uh and the nice thing is that um
you can model multiple Gaussians or
essentially any distribution that you
could model with a mixture of Gaussians.
Um one thing to note here is that you
typically need to predetermine um how
many modes uh you want. Let's say there
are 10. Um but, you know, if you want to
like control like a humanoid, you know,
maybe you want a thousand modes. Uh and
you know, then things start to get quite
tricky.
Um what if we want to model uh
uh what if we want to represent any dis-
arbitrary complex distribution without
this constraint?
Um so, one powerful way to do this is
through discretization. So, instead of
predicting continuous values for an
action, we can kind of turn the action
space into grids uh of bins and then
treat this as a classification problem.
And so, discretization is a good way to
uh represent multimodal distributions,
uh such as, for example, for the drone
flying case or the the the car. Um but,
it's kind of difficult to um apply
naively for higher dimensional spaces
because the number you need um increases
exponentially with higher dimensions.
Um so, one um solution is um
uh doing uh autoregressive per-dimension
discretization, uh which is then uh
linear in the number of dimensions,
uh and um you can then use kind of a a
sequence model like a like a
autoregressive transformer to deco-
decompose this.
Uh and this is essentially how, let's
say, the first VLAs were were doing
this. Um uh let's do the questions later
um so we can get on time. Um, and, um,
how this works is that then you
autoregressively predict, um, every
action dimension. And, um,
with the with the chain rule then you
can see that, uh, this ends up, you
know, um, predicting, um, kind of the
probability of the action, um, given the
the state. Um,
so the, uh, so this is very nice, but,
um, one thing to consider here is that,
you know, the these will this will kind
of force you, uh, to use large
autoregressive models like LLMs or VLMs,
um, to do that as a backbone. And, you
know, this might be a bit, uh, more
expensive computationally.
Um,
exactly. So, you will like kind of
uh, sequentially go go and predict like
each individual action dimension. So, if
it's like your 7 degrees of freedom, uh,
manipulator, then, you know, you will
predict predict each, uh, dimension
separately.
Um, another popular way to handle
multimodality comes from generative
modeling, um, specially diffusion. Um,
you've likely seen these in the context
of generative art where a model turns,
um, random noise into high-fidelity
images. Um, uh, we will talk more in
detail about this, uh, later in in week
six, but this is kind of like a very,
you know, like 1-minute version, uh, of
how you can think about this. Um, so,
um,
the the process is twofold. Um, like you
have, uh, the the forward process where
you can take a clean sample, um, like
this, uh, image of a cat, and then, uh,
you iteratively add Gaussian noise until
all information is kind of lost and
you're, uh, left with, uh, static noise.
And then you have the generative
backward process where, um, you train a
neural network to denoise that, uh, step
by step, uh, and learn how to recover,
uh, of data from, uh, noise.
And, um, so essentially, you, you know,
you create a fake training set, um,
uh, by creating images with various
levels of noise, um, and then train this
this denoising network to, uh, kind of
predict, uh, cleaner versions of the
image.
Um,
maybe one thing to note is that, um,
actually, instead of predicting the full
image, uh, during denoising, we actually
predict the noise itself, and then
subtractive subtractive from the
current, um,
sample to iteratively recover the the
the, uh, clean signal.
And so, both autoregressive
discretization and, uh, diffusion use
sort of a iterative process where, um,
where one is iterative over the action
dimensions, and the other over the
denoising process.
Okay, and, um, kind of the last toolkit,
um, to handle multimodality are latent
variable models,
uh, which can represent any distribution
in principle, as long as the network is
big enough.
Um, in latent variable models, the, um,
output of the network is still a
Gaussian, but in addition to the image,
it receives an additional input, uh,
that is sampled from a prior, uh,
distribution, um, let's say, like a zero
mean, uh, variant Gaussian.
Um, so this is kind of like a seed for
the network.
Um, um, and it will, um, kind of result
in, um, the network predicting different
modes, or different behaviors. So,
obviously, you cannot just like input
random numbers, uh, to get the target
behavior. Um, so we need to train the
model to kind of relate this input
latent variables, uh, with the desired
mode, right? And so, you can think of
this as, um,
you know, uh, we could have these two
modes, like like, uh, going left through
the uh, through the tree, and and right,
and then we kind of like condition our
decoder on this latent to to kind of
tell it like, oh, it's left or it's it's
right, right?
Um
Um now, I want to address a common point
of confusion, um
the difference between the latent intent
and the task specification.
Um so, task conditioning is kind of this
supervised signal where you tell the
robot which specific behavior to execute
like, um opening a drawer,
uh and so it kind of defines the goal,
um and the latent variable tells kind of
the style or mode within that goal that
you want it to represent. Um so, even
for a fixed task ID, um
the robot might still face infinite ways
how to achieve it, right? So, as we just
discussed with the uh drawer opening
example.
Okay.
Uh
So, imagine that now, you know, like we
actually want to learn multiple tasks
with our policy, right?
And imagine that uh
the task is to uh move the sliding door
to the left, right? So, imagine this is
our task ID,
uh and we we are like modeling this
distribution. Um
So,
one thing to note here uh is that in the
real world, it's kind of difficult to
define task success,
right? So, in this example, um the robot
moves the sliding door
I don't know, around halfway, right?
So, what does this tell us? Like, did it
succeed or not?
Like, if we make if we do a poll, like
probably like some of you will say like,
yeah, I think this is good enough.
Others will say like, no, it should be
like closer all the way, right? And this
is like kind of an inherent problem,
um because there is a tendency to think
that the behaviors we want for our
agents are a set of discrete tasks, you
know, like moving the sliding door,
opening a door, uh uh slide sliding with
uh door.
Um but it's difficult to draw a boundary
where a task begins and ends because uh
you know, they're typically made up of
smaller subtasks and skills
and the world is like not discrete, but
it's continuous, right? And so, you
know, in principle, we would want our
robots to learn the full spectrum of
skills that are available in the uh
environment. And so, this motivates kind
of having goal-reaching as an objective
where um goal-reaching we define a
policy that
ends up reaching any desirable goal
state from any other
initial state on the scene.
Uh so, you can see here kind of the
difference between trying to model like
a single task uh
to model like, you know, with a task ID
like a one-hot encoding or like a
natural language could also be
uh or having like goal-reaching. So,
conditioning on two states, an initial
state and a goal state.
Um the nice thing about goal-reaching is
that um the task because the tasks are
continuous, the states are also
continuous.
Okay, so let's put everything together.
Um
I will kind of show a case study of how
we can combine a latent variable model
that handles multimodality
with kind of trying to learn like
task-agnostic control.
Um so, one way to do so is using kind of
undirected unstructured play data where
users teleoperate a robot without doing
any specific task. Um and so, you kind
of like give them like, you know, let
the teleop and they collect, you know,
data. Um
Um but the it's like very very
multimodal. So, it's reset free. You
don't have to like, you know, reset
after opening the drawer. Um but also um
yeah, it's it's kind of like very
scalable data because um
uh essentially an operator engages in
behavior that, uh, satisfies their own
curiosity,
um, which, if you think about it, is not
unlike how, uh, children start learning.
Right? Like, they're also kind of
exploring and playing with the
environment.
So, how can we, uh, now use this latent
variable models with goal conditioning
to learn from this data? Um,
so, we start by sampling a random window
of play data, such as this one. So, this
will be like one sequence.
And then we encode the last frame of the
sampled window through a goal encoder,
uh, as we will use goal relabeling to
learn control. So, this means that we
sample random windows of, uh, frames and
then ask the model to predict a series
of actions associated, uh, or taken
during that sequence to learn how to
mimic that, how to reach, uh,
um,
that goal.
Okay. Now, the trick here is that we
address this inherent multimodality in
the sort of free-form imitation data
set, um, meaning that, you know, there
might be many, many valid observations
that, uh, connect the same initial and
goal state by autoencoding contextual
demonstrations through this kind of
latent plan space, uh, with a
sequence-to-sequence, uh, varia-
conditional variational autoencoder. So,
we have here this dis- posterior and,
um, and this prior.
And so, the posterior will take this
sampled sequence, um, recognizing the
exact behavior,
uh, executed, and then the the prior or
the the plan proposal or sampler,
uh, will take the initial and and goal
state, outputting a distribution over
all possible, uh, behaviors that connect
the initial to the goal state. And then
we minimize the KL divergence between
these two encoders, making the prior
assign high likelihood to behavior that
were actually executed during play. And
then at test time, we will, uh, discard
the posterior and use this plan sampler
to predict multimodal plans.
And so, the trick here is that by
feeding this short horizon goal image
demonstrations into a simple maximum
likelihood imitation objective, we can
now learn kind of task-agnostic control
in a fully self-supervised manner uh
from this multimodal uh play data.
And critically, um conditioning the
policy or the decoder on the uh latent
plan frees up the capacity um
uh of the uh decoder um to learn uh
unimodal behavior um cuz you are like
this is this kind of like latent uh
variable.
Um maybe one last note, um can we do
this also for language goals?
Um cuz like for now, this was kind of
using the the the goal images, right?
From the feed um from the
demonstrations. Uh we can also do this
the same efficiently for language. Um
the key insight here is that uh we can
kind of uh inter- interchange um
uh visual goals with uh embeddings of uh
natural language goals, um allowing to
learn control mostly self-supervisedly
um from unlabeled visual play data and
reduce the burden of uh language
annotations.
Um
I think I'm a little bit out of time to
go into a greater detail of the math uh
behind this.
But um kind of um on a very high level,
um
in order to train this, uh
the the thing is that um we would want
to maximize the the marginal likelihood
of our expert data, but there is kind of
like one issue um because um our Z uh
latent variable is continuous,
um the marginalization becomes
intractable. Um and so, we You just
integrate over an infinite number of
possible plans. And so, in order to
solve this issue,
what you typically do is you use um
a standard variational inference trick,
where in instead of optimizing the
likelihood directly, you optimize a
surrogate objective, which is the
variational lower bound.
Um and so, you have like these two uh
terms, um
the reconstruction One of them uh tells
you
how well does the latent plan explain
the expert behavior. And then the other
one is the regularization
uh that
tells you how close is is the one is the
uh is the Z to the prior distribution
over your trajectories.
Um
And so, like when you then introduce
goal conditioning,
if you have like this context kind of
variable containing SC and SG, um this
then nicely aligns with these like three
components we saw on this architecture
with the posterior, prior, and the
action decoder.
And
and the nice thing about this this this
this problem is that we have factorized
this problem um
in into this latent plans that frees up
the capacity of the decoder for a
learning only unimodal behavior.
Um
Side note, a lot of my PhD work also was
using uh like learning from play data
and using kind of this latent variable
models. So, if you're interested more in
this, um you can look at some of these
papers.
And
to conclude today's lecture, we have
talked about imitation learning um in
its most simple form.
We have
explained how we can make the the
visited by the expert and the states
visited by the policy become closer with
dagger and online interventions. And
then we have addressed some common
pitfalls in imitation learning such as
non-Markovian behaviors from the
demonstrators. And we talked also about
some possible things that you can do to
alleviate them and also multimodal
behavior. And a few
like
solutions or tools
how you can try to alleviate them.
With this thank you for your attention
and yeah.
Let's go with the papers.